[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
derek schoeman's attorney is demanding a
new trial arguing the jury felt
race-based pressure to convict for the
murder of george floyd
we asked famed criminal defense attorney
f lee bailey about the former cops
appeal
i don't think the trial should have been
held there and
a wisconsin man charged in a triple
shooting takes the stand
why joshua 8 is now claiming
self-defense at that point
i shot plus who's really the face behind
the killer clown cold case
attorneys for sheila keen warren now
claim key dna evidence was contaminated
and day two of the testimony in ohio
trial of a man charged with killing his
roommate and dismembering his body
what the defendant allegedly told his
friend the day after the murder
he said when he woke up he was gone law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
derek shopin is now requesting a new
trial in the death of george floyd
law in crime's angenette levy is here to
explain what the former minneapolis
police officer is arguing
brian derrick chauvin filed this notice
with the court and it he outlines 10
reasons why he says his trial wasn't
fair
it includes claims of prosecutorial and
juror misconduct
members of the jury i understand you
have a verdict derek chovin
claims he didn't get a fair trial and he
blames judge cahill
chovin says cahill abused his discretion
when he denied a request for change of
venue
he cites the sam shepard case shepard
got a new trial in 1966
after the u.s supreme court found
prejudicial pre-trial publicity
made it impossible for shepard to get a
fair trial in cleveland where he was
convicted of murdering his wife
etheley bailey represented shepard and
talks about the chauvin case
do you think he was able to get a fair
trial well i would have to say it's
extremely
doubtful bailey believes hennepin county
was the wrong place to hold the trial
first of all i don't think the trial
should have been held there
it should have been moved minneapolis
was
far too much under the gun for really
egregious
police misconduct chauvin also alleges
misconduct by prosecutors with
statements like this because you're
afraid that he would come too
with no pulse and rampage the city
that's the sort of thing you see in
halloween movies ladies and gentlemen
not in real life
chauvin goes on to claim that the
defense's expert witnesses were
intimidated someone threw pigs blood on
a home where use of force expert barry
broad
once lived i'm fearful of
criminal charges going forward and
chauvin brings up maurice hall
the defense told the jury they'd hear
from hall about what was going on
in the suv with floyd the day he died
floyd's girlfriend testified they had
bought drugs from hall
but hall invoked his fifth amendment
right against self-incrimination
his lawyer said his testimony could
result in his being charged with third
degree murder in floyd's death
had he provided drugs to floyd cahill
ruled the jury wouldn't be allowed to
hear about hall's interview with law
enforcement
and that hall would not have to testify
a spokesperson for the minnesota
attorney general's office tells law and
crime
the court has already rejected many of
these arguments
and the state will vigorously oppose
them the defense also requests a
schwartz hearing to investigate juror
misconduct
a photo has surfaced of one juror
wearing a black lives matter hat
and t-shirt at an event last summer
marked get your knee off of our necks
had he disclosed that he was at that
march
with a black lives matter shirt saying
get your knee off
our necks mr nelson the defense attorney
probably would have struck him
minneapolis defense attorney joe
tamborino watched the trial
and read shobin's filing based on all of
that he's definitely got an argument
still an uphill battle but he's got an
argument
now we don't know what derek chauvin's
attorney eric nelson will be outlining
in the brief that he files to support
these motions
but we do know this came when it did it
was filed on the day that it was
because under minnesota law it has to be
filed with the court
15 days after the verdict brian
thanks angeannette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and terry austin
bernard most of the reasons nelson
argues chauvin didn't get a fair trial
involved judge cahill where do you see
the strongest and maybe the weakest
arguments though
so i think probably the strongest
argument may be dealing with the
superstation of the jury because it's an
issue that arose from the very beginning
all the way until the end of the trial
there was always something that was
coming up
in the media and in addition to that
remember that
during the trial that dante wright was
also killed
causing some mayhem also in the city so
so much happened during the trial that i
think if you would have sequestered the
jury
the jury wouldn't have been made aware
of those situations
in addition to that every day going to a
courthouse
that was built like a fort because of so
much security
of the threat that the city had having
to do with this trial
under so now terry nelson also argued
prosecutor misconduct
for disparaging chauvin improper
vouching and not prepping witnesses what
did you make of
those arguments well you know i think he
has to make the argument and what he's
trying to say
is that his client was denied due
process under the constitution but
disparaging the defense i think is not
really a good example
of that because just because the the
prosecution basically said that
a number of comments including that the
defense was
shading the truth i don't think that's
really disparaging that's making an
argument
he talked about improper vouching which
is basically saying that the prosecution
knows more than anybody else and because
of that
the prosecution witnesses are credible
or the prosecution
is a representative of the state and so
the prosecution knows
more and i don't know what he means by
failing to adequately prepare its
witnesses that one hopefully he'll
describe that more in the brief because
the motion didn't say anything about
that
exactly no angelite morris hall who
you've interviewed was
also mentioned what did you make of
nelson's argument that hall should have
testified
well i think it's interesting because he
cites the confrontation clause
when making the argument or the the
statement that hall should have been
forced to testify
and it's interesting to me because we
see maurice hall on video
we hear from him in the trial he's the
only witness though that was in that
vehicle with george floyd that didn't
testify
shawanda hill was in that vehicle and
she testified and she was subjected to
cross-examination
maurice hall was not so whether or not
that argument holds water i don't know
but i think it's an interesting argument
to make
interesting and we'll definitely see if
it holds water and be sure to tune in to
the law and crime network this friday at
9 00 pm
for an hour-long special on the derek
chauvin trial hosted by our own
angenette levy
and now to georgia where a board has
reversed the termination of the former
police officer charge
in the death of rayshard brooks
officials say brooks was shot and killed
last summer in a wendy's parking lot
by atlanta police officer garrett rolfe
rolfe was awaiting trial for 11 charges
including murder and aggravated assault
he was fired by the police chief two
days after the shooting
ralph appealed saying he was not
afforded his right to due process
now the atlanta civil service board has
revoked his dismissal
as an employee ruling rolfe was not
given a 10-day notice of termination
still ahead on law and crime daily one
florida clown could be a killer
why evidence in this decades old cold
case is now being questioned
but first a wisconsin man accused of
murder says the court has it all wrong
the dramatic testimony as a defendant
takes a stand in his own defense on the
other side of this break
[Music]
welcome back wisconsin man on trial for
murder and attempted murder
took the stand explaining to the jury a
triple shooting was in self-defense
i let out kind of a plea for help
of boo what are you doing
her dad is shoving me joshua 8 is
accused of murder and attempted murder
but according to aid the three people he
shot were trying to kill him
at that point her dad struck me in my
left
side aide says he was defending himself
against his ex-girlfriend
rebecca borkowski his stepfather james
gruntner and their family friend
john miller do you anticipate that the
evidence will show
that this was the case of the conspiracy
the conspiracy between
rebecca murkowski her mother julie
bruttner
stepfather jim brittner and john miller
to kill joshua 8.
the defense waited to give their opening
statement until day three of the trial
before their client took the stand why
did you shoot at him
because he was also making an attempt
to induce very bodily harm or kill me
basically
i don't know if his attempt was to
attack me while my back was
at them or not did you feel like you had
any choice at that point about the fire
i didn't know all right i got my vehicle
up right now it's a good time to take a
break
that's when the judge called for a
mid-morning break after the jury left
he had this to say to the defense i
don't know who's talked
who's testifying here mr steven or
this individual so thank you
let's start having him testify on cross
the state asked if the shooting was
fueled by aid trying to desperately get
back together with bronkowski
it's true that you called rebecca over
40 times that day
it is is it fair to say that that's
pretty
obsessive behavior calling someone 40
times in a day
i would not agree with its obsessive
behavior i don't know if the calls were
going through at the time
prosecutors then asked aide why he
couldn't have used his skills from years
in the marines to disarm the victim
and you weren't able to do anything to
defend yourself short of pointing
a red laser at james and shooting in the
head
miss nash the the feelings that i was
feeling
at that point were that i was being
ambushed
and attacked and literally three
individuals
dumped my head into a bucket of water
and
i let out a breath of air which was my
plea to rebecca for help and no one
came you dumped your head in a bucket of
water i'm trying to explain the emotions
that i felt at that time this nation i
never claimed that they physically did
it
okay but you're just saying that they
made eye contact and weren't doing
anything
they were not stopping they were not
stopping james from assaulting me now
but again you're a 20-year marine and
he's a man in his late 50s with a bad
back there's probably some sort of
defensive intervention you could have
attempted at that point
i don't believe so much they were
clearly making an attempt out of my life
back with us as criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and terry
austin
both sides have arrested meaning all of
the evidence has been presented to the
jury
terry eight broke down while crying on
the stand and explained it was three
against one
did his testimony create any doubts
about the state's case
absolutely not i do not think his
testimony was credible at all i don't
think the jury is buying it for one
second i don't think they bought the
tears listen he had
many excuses for almost everything he
tried to explain why he didn't call the
police
he tried to explain why he didn't use
his self-defense as opposed to the gun
i think there's no question that he's
just trying to explain away everything
and it really doesn't make sense and it
hasn't caused any doubt
and the other thing that i will mention
which was extremely annoying well two
things one he wore a mask
take it off so the jury can hear you but
two don't
belittle the prosecution by every two
seconds that's correct ms nash that's
correct ms nash no just
be more respectful and don't call her by
her name at every certain
you know point in the testimony so i
don't think he was very good when he was
on a stand
now bernard defense attorneys don't
usually put their client on the stand or
they don't usually make it to the stand
to testify
but this case kind of called for it um
how do you think he held up on cross
though
he didn't brian that's the problem he
did it but he was forced to testify
because when you're alleging and
claiming that you acted as a result of
self-defense that you had to in order to
preserve your life
you have no choice but to have to
testify because you don't have anyone
else
that's going to testify for you to tell
the jury
what's in your mind so you have to take
the stance to be able to explain that to
the jury
but in this case he definitely did not
meet out self-defense when you're
talking about taking a deadly weapon and
aiming and shooting three people in the
head
no no way around it yeah the head part
is definitely difficult there
thank you both for commentary coming up
on law and crime daily
key testimony as an ohio man stands
trial in the murder and dismemberment
of his roommate plus the killer clown
cold case cracked thanks to dna evidence
why the defense is now saying a fiber
found on a balloon decades later
might be contaminated
we're back attorneys for a so-called
killer clown are raising
the alarm about key evidence used to
crack a nearly three decades-old cold
case
balloons flowers and the face of a clown
were the last thing marlene warren saw
before she was shot and killed as she
opened her front door to her home
in wellington florida in 1990.
investigators long suspected her husband
michael warren
and his mistress sheila keane the two
moved to virginia and later married
the big break in the case came in 2017
when prosecutors retested evidence
and say dna found on fibers matched the
now sheila keen warren
but keen warren's defense now says that
evidence might have been contaminated
and want to speak to the spokesperson
for the district attorney's office about
comments he made
to a newspaper in 1990 this exact
evidence was reviewed by pbso crime lab
and the fbi and they did not find a six
to eight inch fiber
exactly what they're looking for when
looking at this balloon ribbon
and then after these bags were found
open in 2013
this fiber suddenly appears and based on
the information the article
one of the boxes that was found in the
hallway contained the wig
so you believe that mr edmonson may have
some information about what happened in
2000
at the very least he could lead us he
might possibly know witnesses we can
speak with
i mean it could lead to relevant
information and that's the standard
here to explain this circus of a
homicide is co-host terry austin
terry you kind of heard it there and it
does make
a lot of sense uh the defense wants to
question uh mike edmondson
executive assistant to the state of
attorney uh for something that happened
in 1999 now the judge has reserved his
decision
but do you think the defense will
prevail in this argument
i do think they should prevail brian
there's no you know reason
to think that they wouldn't if edmonson
has any information at all that's
relevant about this evidence
so for instance whether he can clarify
the chain of custody
whether or not the fibers were tested
when would they test it what would the
results of those tests
i think all of that would be helpful to
both sides and
if in fact it was contaminated we need
to know that information so
i think the judge should really decide
that edmondson could testify and lead to
more evidence as far as this is
concerned yeah now i know you're saying
should so i think there's some
skepticism as to whether or not the
judge
will decide it and i agree with you
there but i think
if he doesn't allow for this to happen
the inference that hey
maybe the attorneys know something that
they're not sharing with the jury might
be pretty powerful for the jury
speaking of the jury this whole didn't
find this six to eight
inch long fiber years later does that
make sense to you
no it doesn't make sense but that's why
i think we need to call edmondson back
to figure out exactly
what did happen with that fiber was it
there wasn't it there
what was the the chain of custody is
what i'd really want to know
it could definitely make for a great
reasonable doubt for the defense thanks
terry
when we come back the case of an accused
killer roommate
why the defendant is saying he was
acting in self-defense before
dismembering and burning a man's remains
[Music]
welcome back an ohio man on trial for
allegedly killing his roommate and
burning the body
is also accused of sexually assaulting
his own daughter
investigators say 56 year old james
whitaker was killed on july 4th
2020. his roommate michael dixon is
accused of shooting whitaker
cutting up his body and burning it
dixon's defense maintains the shooting
was to protect his 18 year old daughter
they say dixon saw whitaker pointing a
gun at her
but the victim's friend says he was
encouraging whitaker to kick dixon out
of his home
because he believed dixon was having a
sexual relationship with his daughter
uh because i believe that uh my cat was
having sexual relations with his
daughter and i thought
nothing good could come of that so when
mr dixon moved in
at the end of 2018 the beginning of 2019
was melody with him
no when did she uh
come around i would say the six
sometimes four to six months
give or take prior to his disappearance
they stayed together when you say
together does that mean they stayed in
the same
basement together correct i never saw
them lie together
but they went to bed together and i
jimmy said that uh
they stayed down there together one
second sir
did jimmy kick him out no no
he i think he
maybe in some way liked having the
company but
he seemed reluctant to make mike leave
on cross-examination the defense asked
about the day the victim is believed to
have been killed
strickland said that he the defendant
and the victim
each did six lines of meth while they
were fixing a car
you've witnessed jimmy using
methamphetamines
he was speeded up his personality was
speeded up is that right
it does that to any human being yes sure
to him as well correct correct does
methamphetamine
make some persons aggressive uh there's
a possibility it could
okay has that have you ever experienced
that no
have you ever witnessed jimmy acting
that way in front of you
no i mean i've seen him get mad but no
not
you know good aggressive towards me as
any human would about
you know things that could make someone
upset okay no
what kind of things would he get upset
about around you nothing in particular
you know but anyone could be emotional
about day-to-day things in their life
that happen that you know they maybe
disagree with or upset them
prosecutors asked strickland what the
defendant told him the following day
when he went back to the victim's home
he said when he woke up he was gone
when michael woke up in the morning he
was gone yeah or when he woke up
whenever yeah he was gone did he say
that
michael excuse me did michael say that
jimmy took anything with him
i say he took his shotgun but the
shotgun was
also gone yes that may have came up i
can't remember that came up
later in talking all right terry let's
break this down we saw the direct and
the cross-examination
strickland's testimony seemed to help
the prosecution a bit but
i can't get over this whole we did six
lines of meth together between
the three of them could that maybe harm
his credibility or how much he
remembered on that day
it definitely will harm his credibility
there's no question if
both you know keith and michael are
doing drugs
and it's the type of drug that will make
you more
animated the fact that you know we know
that michael dixon is the defendant here
and that
the allegation is he murdered james
whitaker i think
very well the prosecution could say that
the drugs in
the system of michael dixon contributed
to the fact that he got aggravated
maybe he was concerned about you know
whether there was any abuse as far as
that was concerned
of the you know woman who's involved so
i
definitely think this is one of those
cases where you're going to have to look
at the physical evidence that's
present because the testimony of these
various witnesses i think
is a bit confusing for the jury to have
to listen to
what's the motive here yeah now terry i
know this hasn't come up in this case
one side is arguing salt defense the
other side saying just a random murder
but could it also be that dixon was
confronted by whitaker
when he found out about the sexual
assault and maybe killed him over that i
don't know
we'll see how that plays out terry thank
you for joining us and thank you for
joining us here at law on crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you